and the thunder were chopping down that
sacramental lead and so a solid
performance by the rookie but with 25.3
seconds left here michael it's
sacramento's turn
to potentially
drop something up here offensively what
are you looking for well you know
they're gonna try to get the ball in the
hands either harrison barnes
or buddy hill i mean either one of those
guys are good at mid-range all they need
is two points if you're the thunder just
play the clock out play good solid
defense the king is going to run it all
the way down
try to see if they can get the last
second shot
sacramento playing for the win it's dork
picking the pocket of fox three on the
timer dort steps in lays it up and in
with 1.7
what a defensive play
not only did he make the biggest
defensive play of the game
he went coast to coast
and finished
through the contact
my goodness
what a series of fortunate defense
throw the thunder on that plate fox lost
the basketball
flat out had his pocket picked
dribbled it off in the laying of dork
and thornton no hesitation whatsoever
goes right at buddy healed with the
scoop and score for the biggest bucket
of the game
and he does a great job of just staying
focused
he didn't celebrate when he stole that
basketball which there's a lot of energy
going through your body at that point
he had the presence of mind and the
focus to say look we need two points to
surge ahead here
and put a lot of pressure on the kings
with 1.7 seconds remaining to come up
with a play
well it was the thunder's best on-ball
defensive player in dort
making the game's biggest play
as sacramento
was holding out to try to settle for the
win or overtime
and not only causing the turnover
michael but then to go right to the rim
with four seconds left covering the
length of the floor
that's a good point she makes a lot of
times you think about holding the
basketball back to try to make a play
he knew he was out front the defense was
behind it and he just bee lined it to
the basket
sacramento is now out of timeouts but
1.7
to try to get off his shot
with the thunder up by two
it's fox from the sideline looking to
get it in to heal healed
has the three and it's off target and
okc
survives with the victory
you ever feel like you want to save
yourself we got to stop meeting like
this
my goodness
what a week of good solid
down to the wire basketball it has been
and the thunder have not done yet
as they come from behind
down by smitty's 18 in the first half to
up in the kings
by a deuce
[Applause]
field got the pass
got a clean look and it never had a
chance it was two feet short
and smiles
as
loud
kisses
sacramento good night
and i will earn victory as well
as you know you talk about gritty and
just doing the dirty work of the game
and then all of a sudden it becomes a
labor of love
in the fourth quarter let's check in
with nick who's with lou lou the biggest
play of the night and you get the job
done tell me about that feeling i mean
we just had to finish the game i know i
know they have one more possession left
i just had to step up and get a stop and
go up strong another comeback now of 16
or more points that's the fourth one
already this season tell me about the
heart of this group we've just got to
compete i mean that's that's one of the
things that the coach emphasized a lot
and and you know we're just listening
and we know we can do it you know we
know we're one of the youngest team but
we just got to come out here and play
hard so many guys stepped up trey mann
darius baisley jeremiah what stood out
to you about the whole group i mean it's
a it's a it's a weird group you know we
all got compete and we're all gone don't
come and step up even though trey went
to the feeling and come back i mean it's
a learning process for him and i'm and
we're all proud of him lou i was told
that this is the first time that your
mom was able to be here in oklahoma city
and watch you play what does this mean
to you to come away with the biggest
play at down the stretch and it means a
lot you know the first time
i mean she's not a lot for me you know
i'm without her i wouldn't be in this
position right now today so you know i
love her to death and and i'm happy
she's here so she can enjoy me playing
good congrats lou enjoy this one thank
you
gotta be a lot of emotion and loud
putting on
a show on the final possession
showing why he is one of the best
on-ball defensive players in the nba and
then the awareness to charge his way
down the floor for the game-winning
deuce which was just enough as okc once
again
with a steep hill to climb did so in the
second half
erasing that 18-point deficit to outlast
sacramento